JEFF BATES: This is
Google on Google--
or, as I added on to this,
(Running) Google on Google.
The focus of this session is
going to be talking about how
we in Corporate Engineering have
kept pace with the growth
of Google over the last
14 years or so.
My name is Jeff Bates.
I'm the open source IT program
manager within Corporate
Engineering.
And with me, as you can see on
this slide as well, is Iustin
Pop, who is a systems engineer
in the tech lead on Ganeti,
which is one of the products
that we built within Corporate
Engineering as well.
So, what is Corporate
Engineering?
I suspect many of you in this
room have been in IT before.
And Corporate Engineering is
what we call IT within Google.
We do a lot of different things
inside of Google.
And I think, as probably a lot
of you can attest to, IT ends
up doing a lot of different
things within a lot of
different companies as well.
In our case, what we really
set out to do is empower
Googlers with world-leading
technologies.
So that can span a wide gamut
of things, from building
systems to giving them
tools to work with.
So to give you a sense of what
it is we do, we are the IT.
What that means is that we're
supporting offices in every
continent in the world except
for Antarctica, which turns
out doesn't have a very large
population, so we haven't
added any offices there yet.
It means we work
with everyone--
[MICROPHONE DROPS]
Yes, we speak very quietly as I
tear the microphone from me.
All right, I think
that works now.
OK.
That's a wardrobe malfunction,
perhaps.
So we support everything from
the real estate services, who
make the actual offices run and
getting people in there,
and the security systems
that are associated
with that as well.
We make sure that everyone is
actually paid on time, because
it turns out people like to do
things like buy food, and
clothing, and go out, and
do things like that.
And they also like to be paid
legally in regularly as well.
As part of that, we also do the
compliance systems that
comes with that.
Because having all these
offices in all of these
different countries means that
there are a lot of--
countries like to do things
differently, it turns out.
And we need to be able to
work with each of those
environments.
Part of what we do as
well is running the
Help Desk within Google.
And that's, again, within all of
the offices that we've got.
We do something--
as I'll talk about later
in the presentation--
we take a very, I think,
innovative and unique approach
to doing that.
We call them Tech
Stops and we--
well, I'll talk in more detail
about that later.
Also, given that it's Google, we
have the all-important task
of making sure that the massage
scheduling takes place
on time, because that is
obviously very critical.
But in addition, for those of
you who are based here in the
Bay Area, you may have seen some
of the buses that go back
and forth from Mountain View and
to the surrounding areas.
Out here in the Bay Area, we end
up running something that
is close to the largest private
bus fleet in the state
of California.
And this kind of gets back to
the idea of being able to
empower Googlers.
Rather than having people sit
in the parking lot that is
referred to as Highway 101, we
want to keep them productive,
we want to keep them efficient,
we want to keep
them happy.
And so when you're running on
the bus to and from work, we
keep WiFi available, so that
people aren't using that time
when they're sitting on 101
having their blood pressure
slowly get higher, but instead
are able to work and are able
to get things done as well.
So part of how we go about
building these systems is like
any company or any
organization.
We have this choice
between buying
systems, building systems.
And we do both within CorpEng.
And sometimes we're buying
something because it's going
to be the best tool
that's available.
Sometimes we're going to build
something because we want to
solve a unique problem.
Or we want to solve a problem
better than we think it has
been solved elsewhere before.
But one of the things we
consistently try to do with
that is sharing the lessons that
we've learned, sometimes
painfully, sometimes
not-quite-so painfully.
So that people don't have to
go out and have the same
problem, and solve the same
problems that we have already
gone through.
That takes a number of
different forms.
At the end of the presentation,
and when this is
posted later, I have a number of
links to some of the other
materials that we've done
before, presentations that
we've given, and other
usage Hangouts on the
air to talk to people.
In the various offices around
the world as well, we host
user groups to come in, from the
Linux user groups to the
Mac admin groups to programming
and other
interdisciplinary
groups as well.
And that includes people both
who work within Google and
people who work elsewhere.
Because it's only by actually
working and sharing the
information together that things
actually move forward.
And rather than seeing people
smash their head in the same
wall that we've had
to, it just--
a rising tide floats
all boats.
The last is conference speaking,
which I think is
probably self-evident
what that is.
I assume if you're here
you recognize that.
And within the links at the
back, we've also got the
office hours that we host, the
IRC, the mailing list that we
do as well.
As I said, we absolutely do buy
software and bring it in
and work with that.
We also build software.
And that is often--
as I alluded to, that's when
we're trying to solve a unique
problem or we're not happy
with the solutions
that are out there.
And what we try to do in that
case is often we will make
that available under various
open-source licenses.
And when I talked about building
the software, I'm
talking about everything
from--
one of the projects that we
have open sourced is a
compliance framework.
And that is for doing legal
compliance and being able to
file the reports is building
a framework.
That is a generic problem.
That is something that people
can reuse that.
So what we built internally, we
then made available to the
rest of the world.
Some of the other things that
we have released recently.
One is the dowdy little
fellow there.
He is in fact a cauliflower, and
he's wearing a vest, which
is appropriate given that it
is called Cauliflower Vest.
That is in fact an anagram for
File Vault Key Escrow.
And part of what the reason for
that is, using the full
disk encryption that Apple
shipped in most recent
versions of the OS X, we wanted
a way to be able to
manage that at scale.
And there was not tools that we
thought were appropriate at
hand to do that.
So we set about building
Cauliflower Vest, and then
released that to the
rest of the world.
Similarly, we have one of the--
we have a very, very
large Mac fleet internally.
And managing that, managing the
licensing, managing the
installation of software, was
a problem that, yeah, there
are solutions that
are out there.
But we figured out a way that
we wanted to do it and built
something called Simian, which
is what we use internally for
managing the software and the
Mac fleet, and have also made
available under an open-source
license.
But this is not just a scenario
in which we try to
build one-off solutions because
we want to build
something unique.
Just as important in that is
contributing back to the other
corpus of works.
So part of what Simian is built
on to something called
Monkey, which is another
open-source tool that was
originally developed by folks
at Walt Disney Studios.
And so it is something where
we will build something
internally, but where we can,
and where it is appropriate,
we will go through and actually
use what else is out
there and contribute back to the
greater body of knowledge.
So, obviously in this case,
I work within Google's IT.
But I think the lessons that
we're talking about here are
something that can be applied
within your own organization,
regardless of your size.
And this isn't something that
needs to be strictly applied
to working with other
internal customers.
This is something where the
lessons we've learned can also
be applied to people
who are working.
If your business is growing,
and you're having to figure
out how you are going to have a
more efficient process, how
to automate more, and how to be
able to do that so that you
can scale with the growth of
your business, I think these
lessons ring true as well.
So to set a sense of
scale of what we've
had to contend with.
Math.
I think it's probably fair to
say 284 and 32,467 are pretty
different numbers.
And for those of you who take
a particular excitement in
reading SEC filings, you can
find in the most recent filing
at the end of Q1 of this year
that Google is just over
33,000 full-time employees
at this point.
As I've said before, this is
also literally in every other
continent but Antarctica.
So this is a challenge both in
terms of the number of people
who are involved, in the sheer
growth on that side, but also
the number of environments that
are working as well, the
number of countries, the sheer
number of different offices.
And I think it's probably also
worth pointing out that the
company that was there in 2001
and 2011, we do a lot of
different stuff.
I'm sure many of you saw the
keynote yesterday talking
about the release
of Jelly Bean.
Jelly Bean wasn't a glimmer
in-- well, maybe it was a
glimmer in Andy's eye in 2001.
We'll see.
But the growth in what the
company has done has been a
very meteoric rise, and
we've had to keep pace
with that as well.
And these are some of
the ways that we've
gone about doing that.
So let's take a practical
use case.
I've long held this semi-private
theory that
tickets ultimately function as a
neural network for a company
or an organization.
I'm sure almost everyone
in this room has work
significantly with tickets in
the past, whether it be bug
trackers, whether it be filing
tickets for HR benefits, for
getting an office set up, for
dealing with the cable
company, for anything
else like that.
And within Google, this is
something that we use a lot.
And by a lot, I mean last year
alone the support organization
had over half a million
tickets.
When talk about the support
organization, I'm talking
about the IT support side.
The total number tickets that
we were dealing with was a
little bit over 2 million
tickets in the
course of one year.
A lot of that is
machine-generated tickets
talking to another machine.
But that level of growth, it
takes a lot of people to go
and deal with those tickets.
And we had to figure out,
especially a few years ago,
how we were going to continue
to grow with that.
Because the number of tickets
kept going up, the number of
different ways that they were
used kept going up, and we had
to figure out a way that this
would continue to be an
efficient way for people to be
able to get things done, and
how we're going to go about
building that tool.
So enter the angry
clothes washer.
This is actually the logo for
one of the tools that we've
built internally that's
called Stuff-O-Matic.
and Stuff-O-Matic is the epitome
of the approach that
we've taken to working
with tickets
and reproducing processes.
So one of the other systems
that we use as
well is called GTR.
And that is Google
Ticket Routing.
As you can see, naming is
something that took a lot of
time on that one.
So up until a few years ago, the
way that we dealt with the
tickets is we had people.
And they would go through and
they would categorize the
tickets, and they would go and
categorize more tickets, and
then they categorize more
tickets, and they would go
through and people would work
off of them and send updates
from there.
But, as we got to this time
frame and the company was
continuing its growth rate, it
became really, really clear
that this was just not going to
be a way that we were going
to be able to grow.
That eventually you reach the
point where you can only have
only so many humans doing
things, and you need to get
computers involved in
making that happen.
So at that point, we said,
well OK, what is
this problem like?
Well, it turns out dealing with
that many tickets is kind
of like dealing with spam.
And I certainly would not want
to impugn that any of my
colleagues are spam farmers or
anything like that, but given
the sheer amount of tickets
they're generating, there is a
great degree of likeness
inside of there.
So what we did is we said, hmm,
all right, what are the
things inside of here that we
can recognize the patterns
from and be able to build an
automated response to this?
Not necessarily a response
that was going
to resolve the ticket--
we did start to do
that later--
but even at that point, just
making sure the tickets ended
up in the right place.
And so we began to put this
system into place.
And that was very,
very key for us.
By running the math, the ability
to use the ticket
routing system--
which has pretty close to a 99.7
success rate for being
able to get the tickets
to the right queues--
in 2010, that saved us roughly
28,000 man hours of time.
In 2011, it saved us 41,000
man hours in time.
And that's a lot of time.
And when you save that much
time, and you save that much
money, you begin to put energy
into doing other things.
Maybe it means hiring
more people.
Maybe it means being able to
look at other problem that you
can reduce down to a
reproducible problem and find
a fix for and address that
particular set of issues.
The other flipside is that
it meant the problems got
resolved more quickly.
It meant that queues--
getting information into
the right category
in the right queue--
happened much more quickly
at that point.
And that meant that you had
a much happier and more
productive staff working
on issues as well.
And this is not like we're
sending a rocket to Mars or
anything like that.
What it is is thinking
thoughtfully about the data
that you have and what is going
to save time, and what
is going to save energy, and
what is going to keep your
team working as efficiently
and happily as possible.
Both in terms of the customers
that you have, and also the
teams that actually
need to work with
these systems as well.
So one of the other things
that we do is--
I alluded to at the beginning--
we're in charge of
running all of the Help
Desk inside of Google.
But, at least in the companies
I've worked in in the past,
sometimes the help desk is
literally someone's desk that
is in a corner, and sometimes
that is how it needs to be.
What we have done at Google
is we've tried to
turn these into centers.
We call them Tech Stops.
And one of the most key things
that we have found inside of
there is the philosophy
of solving the
problem at first contact.
So when someone comes in, and
they walk into a Tech Stop,
and they're having a problem
with their machine, is how
quickly can you solve
that problem?
Or if they don't want to walk
into a Tech Stop, or they're
working from home, you provide
the services to them in the
way that is going to be most
convenient for them.
Whether that be that via video
chat, or whether that be via
text chat, or whether that be
self-service through being
able to find the information
online.
You want to get them the
information as efficiently and
quickly as possible.
And part of that is also
choosing who you hire into
that organization.
What we look for when we want
to hire people into there is
people who, at a small company,
that might be the IT
guy or the sysadmin that
is inside of there.
My friend Rob Malda, he
and I started a site
called Slashdot together.
And he was often asked
to describe the
demographic of the site.
And, believe you me, there
is no way to describe the
demographic.
But he had a choice phrase,
which I think is an apt
description for the
people who we want
working the Tech Stops.
It's people who have the love of
technology in their blood.
It's people who are passionate
about technology.
They're genderless, they're
intellectually curious, and
they want to learn more.
So you bring these people inside
of the organization.
And in some cases, we use this
model that's been around for
about 2000 years or so called
an apprenticeship, where you
bring in people who are curious
and want to learn more
and you have been paired with
people who have been doing
this for a while and they
learn from them.
And it turns out everyone
is far happier and more
productive in that process.
So I know that this sounds
all well and good.
That, well you're Google, of
course you've been able to do
this, you just hire all the
people and put it in there.
What we have found by running
all the numbers is that
actually, our cost to provide
support within the company is
well below what the industry
average for support is.
Because rather than focusing
on how much you can squeeze
out of it, you want to get
people to be as productive and
efficient and quickly
as possible.
Back to work as quickly
Because it might in one sense be
like, well they have to do
this this way, they have
to do this this way.
No, what you really want to do
is you want to have someone
come in, get their problem
solved, and be back to writing
code as quickly as possible.
Because them writing
code matters
far more than whether--
It's just a lot more pleasant
for everyone
who's involved in that.
Part of how we've gone about
doing that is really a
two-fold side of choice
and transparency.
You want to give people a choice
so that they're using
the tools that are the most
effective for them.
So you come to work
at Google--
Iustin is running--
well, the laptop's closed, but
he's running Linux over there.
I'm running this is
off of a MacBook.
You come in, you've got
a choice between them.
And it's not like we're running
a commune where you
can run whatever you want to
or something like that.
You need to have everything
within the bounds of keeping
the data and information
secure and
safe and easily available.
But you're trying to hire the
smartest people that you
possibly can, regardless of the
company that you're in.
So trying to constrain their
choice and make them use
something that they're going to
be less effective in would
seem, to me at least, to be
pretty counterproductive at
that point.
So we give them a choice.
Part of it as well is also,
especially over the last
several years, has
been changing how
you deliver the services.
Ultimately, the mindset of
making people operate within
the constraints of how you
want them to and is most
convenient for you,
that's riding the
failboat at that point.
So what that is meant is
delivering far more of the
services through mobile
platform, or delivering it in
a way they can access
it at home.
Something like that.
It's kind of hard to see here on
this slide here, but on the
right side is a wire
frame rack.
This is something that is a
common feature throughout the
Tech Stops and throughout
the organization.
And what that is, is that
you walk into the Tech
Stop, and we have--
let's see, on there is ethernet
cables, it's power
adapters, it's headphones, its
cable organizers, it is all
the various miscellaneous items
that you need to get
your work done.
And what we do is you walk in,
you swipe your badge, you use
the little scan gun, and you
check the stuff out,
and you walk away.
But all right, so
that's great.
That saves a lot of time.
Rather than making someone file
a PO so that they can
order a new mouse--
a mouse costs almost nothing at
this point and you've just
wasted a lot of time
making people jump
through that hoop--
so make it easy for them
to come up and get it.
But part of that, back to hiring
smart people, is also
treating them like adults.
So when they come in, there is a
price for everything that is
listed on there.
We obviously don't charge them
for that, but we keep track of
all of that.
And so what that means is that
when people come in, and they
get one of these items, they can
see all of the other stuff
that they've gotten over time.
And the interesting side effect
of that is it turns
out, when you treat people
like adults they actually
reciprocate.
And so what happens is that when
people are using some of
these items and they don't need
it anymore, they will
come back and they'll check it
back in and put it away.
So you get this constant cycle
of people using items.
And it goes back to treat people
the way that you would
like to be treated.
So one of the other things
that has been key for our
ability to grow has been
using our own tools.
My Gmail, that I use every day
while I'm at work, is the
Gmail that you, well hopefully,
are using to check
your email as well.
A lot of these tools we have
built for ourselves internally
to solve problems.
And, because we're solving
generic problems, then sharing
it out with the world.
The calendar really came about
because we weren't happy with
the calendar tools that
we have within Google.
We said, all right, we can
do a better job for this.
Because scheduling meetings
across time zones and
everything was not a
particularly pleasant process.
And so when we built this, we
then said, well all right,
we're pretty happy with this.
How about we make this available
to everyone else?
And this continues to
grow out over time.
I mean, it's now been, I think,
a year in a day since
Google+ was officially rolled
out, and part of the success
of Google+ has been the
inclusion of the Hangouts.
And part of where Hangouts
came from was, Google is
something like the world's
largest private civilian-user
video conferencing.
Again, we've got all
these offices and
everything else like that.
It makes a huge difference,
when you can actually see
someone on the other end, and
you can communicate with them,
and you can see the body
language, and you can see what
they're saying.
That is a far more efficient
way for doing things.
And we took the knowledge that
we had learned from that and
said, well, this is something
that we should make available
to the rest of world.
Yeah, Gmail was letting you do
a chat, do video chat and
things like that.
But what Hangouts meant
is that it became a
much broader affair.
So you could have people
in different locations.
And this goes back to the idea
of these problems that we try
to solve for ourselves, we also
want to make available to
the rest of the world, too.
So foresight.
I suppose another word for
foresight would be
"proactive," but I really,
really can't stand the word
"proactive," although it's
a fairly apt description.
The ability to see what is
coming down the road.
And the way that you can see
what is coming up is by--
people talk about big data.
I'd actually like all data.
On a practical basis, you should
keep all of the logs
and all of the data that you
possibly can, because it's
only by looking at that data,
and it's only by looking that
information, that you're going
to be able to figure out the
problem that you need to solve
for 18 months from now, or two
or two years from now.
Because, as your business grows,
or as your organization
grows, whatever you're doing
grows, what is a minor
irritant to you right now is
going to become a giant
flaming problem for you
18 months from now.
At least hopefully, as odd as
that sentence may sound.
And it's by looking at that
stuff and by having that
available that you'll know what
problems it is that you
need to address at that point.
I know that that's probably
gravitational impossible.
Unless the rock on the right
is a particularly
porous form of rock.
But what that comes down to is
how do you keep this balance
inside of there, and how are you
able to continue to grow?
If I could say, one of the best
things I've learned over
time is, do not be beholden
to the past.
So that has taken a number
of different forms within
Corporate Engineering.
One of them is, is that little
bit, about 2 and 1/2 years ago
now, we began moving more and
more of our apps into Google's
cloud platform.
And I'm not going to say that it
was unicorns and fairy dust
to start that from
the beginning.
It requires a whole different
way of doing things.
But once we started doing that,
and the benefits that we
got from that, is--
so, within the support
organization, for instance, it
takes us 25% less time
to deliver new apps.
Simply because of the ease of
being able to deploy on the
cloud platform, and to build
something new, and to have it
rolled out and delivered.
And one of the other benefits
that has come from that is
that we haven't had to get any
new pagers for people in the
last couple years.
Because we've been able to take
that problem of providing
operational support and make it
someone else's problem at
that point, actually.
But what that means is you don't
have people having to
get up in the middle of the
night and try to solve a
problem, because you can rely
on the platform as a service
to actually deal with that.
And when you don't have to do
that, then you go back and you
can start to look
at your data.
And you can start to figure
out what you need to do to
move things forward.
The other point I would make
as well, with that, is that
thinking about how you operate,
and changing that.
So an example is, within
support, in the last couple
years, the number of people that
the support organization
actually supports has
grown by 68%.
That's a lot of people.
The support organization
has grown by 4%.
4 and 68 are not close
to each other--
well, I guess it depends on
your sense of scale--
but they're pretty far off from
each other at that point.
So how were we able
to do that?
We were able to do that because
we went through and we
said, OK, what's the information
people really
want, and what is the best
way to deliver that?
So making better tools
available, making it so the
people can actually--
again, this kind of like
proactive in that I hate the
word, but it's accurate--
crowdsourcing.
Where people who have solved a
particular edge-case problem
are able to share that
with each other.
And that has led to a far
greater efficiency and
productivity with that.
But by the same notion of also
not being beholden to the
past, you need to realize that
sometimes the problems you
solve are ones that aren't
going to be answered by
necessarily going into the
cloud or changing your
traditional IT stack.
And we still do run many
apps like that.
And Iustin, who will be talking
next, is in charge of
Ganeti, which is one of the
ways that we go about
supporting that.
IUSTIN POP: Thanks, Jeff.
So, I everyone.
My name is Iustin Pop,
and I work in the
Google Switzerland office.
And for most of my lifetime
in Google, I've
been working on Ganeti.
What is Ganeti?
If you go to the project
homepage, you will see there
are some very nice words.
Open source, cluster-based
virtualization manager.
And what it actually means is
that about six years ago, we
said we want to start using
virtualization in our IT fleet.
And through the process which
Jeff described, we want to
look at what the projects
were there.
And of course, there was already
VMware, there was some
open-source stuff, and so on.
But none of the tools at that
time offered what we wanted, a
way to scale from very small
deployments to large
deployments while at the same
time not depending on external
infrastructure like share
storage or very expensive
networking gear and so on.
So we said, let's go build
something simple, we'll run it
for a couple of years on
a small scale, and
that will be it.
However, it didn't turn out
that simple in the end.
Now we are still running Ganeti,
and we manage with it
almost all the internal
virtualized fleet.
We run it both in the offices
that Jeff mentioned, across
the whole world, where we run
Ganeti, for example, in very
small deployments.
Like two, three physical
machines managed by Ganeti,
which provide around 15 or
20 virtual machines.
And we also run it at the other
end of the scale, in
data centers where we have
various workloads like
engineers that don't run
a [INAUDIBLE] stack the
application cannot be moved to
the cloud yet, or so on.
Or virtual workstations, which
we use a lot, and so on.
So the scale that
Ganeti covers--
from one, two physical machines
to 100 or 200
physical machines, depending
to order of magnitude--
means that there's a lot of
balance needed to make sure
that Ganeti works well, both for
the lower end of the scale
and for high end.
So, for example, challenges
here are, we don't want
someone who tries Ganeti at
first, for example, runs
Debian or Ubuntu and just runs
app Ganeti and store Ganeti
and configures the cluster.
we don't want this person to be
burdened by a very complex
setup procedure, and requiring
a very complex software
environment.
At the other end of the scale,
we don't want that scaling
Ganeti up is hampered by the
fact that it also supports
very small environments.
So there's, as Jeff mentioned,
scale of scaling, or the
problems in scaling up also
appear, not only in the
organization, but also in the
kind of software development
products that we do
in Corporate IT.
And to help solve this, what
we did in Ganeti is simply
make sure that the way we
[INAUDIBLE] the Ganeti is to
allow for incremental
improvements and scalability
and not requiring you, when you
move, for example, from 10
physical machines to 100
physical machines, to change
the way you deploy Ganeti or
the actual features that
Ganeti offers you.
And today, I think we were
pretty successful with that.
You can start with installing
Ganeti on a single laptop, and
then keep adding physical
machines to this environment
and scale it up to 100 machines,
and it works well.
We still have, of course, some
corner issues, some cases
where scalability's
not that good.
But overall, it works for us,
and we use it, as I said,
extensively.
Another problem that we have
with Ganeti is that, as I
said, it's an open-source
project, and we want run it as
an open source project.
But this raises some
questions.
For example, when we want to
add the new feature, it's
always a question,
is this feature
Google-specific, for example?
Is this feature something that
will only be useful for large
deployments, or is it something
that is generic?
And not only on the feature
side, but, for example, how do
we deal with designing Ganeti?
Do we keep it a purely internal
issue, and do we do a
closed-design process, and
then just make releases
externally?
Or we actually have an
open-source design process,
and if so, how do we deal
with things that are
Google-specific or, for example,
depend on the kind of
hardware that you run Ganeti
on, inside Google or
networking, and so on.
So what we've tried is to make
sure that if you run a single
Ganeti cluster and you don't
need a lot of automation, then
you get the same features
as you have in Google.
So by installing Ganeti from
Debian, you get exactly the
same Ganeti as you run
internally, on a single
cluster, let's say.
Where we have internal
components, then is when we
tie into the Google-specific
features like integration with
machine management, integration
with monitoring,
the integration with repairs,
workflow, and so on.
Now, it would be nice if we
could open all of these, but
they are mostly
corporation-specific or
deployment-specific.
Here we have done other
presentations, and you can
find slides onto the project
website where we describe what
we cannot open source.
At least we describe the
software that we run together
with Ganeti internally and the
way we deploy it internally,
so that if you need to have a
large deployment, you can
duplicate it also.
There are a couple of
open-source alternatives to
the tools we use internally.
Of course, there are monitoring
solutions like
Nagios and so on, and people
integrate that very
successfully with Ganeti.
There are also some open-source,
web-based
interfaces to Ganeti which you
can use today and they work.
Another issue that--
again, it's a problem of
scaling-- is that originally
we envisioned a small
deployment of
Ganeti inside Google.
So Ganeti started simply as a
command-line tool designed by
sysadmins for sysadmins.
So this can still be seen today
in the fact Ganeti is
mainly a command-line
application, which might seem
outdated in today's world.
We realized this after while,
that once we deployed more and
more, Ganeti was not the best
way to actually automate
interaction with
Ganeti itself.
So we started adding
an HTTP-based API.
It's a REST-based, JSON
encoding and so on.
Very standard.
And today we have full parity
on the virtual machine
operations, but not on the
cluster management operations.
So, for example, if you just
want to create virtual
machines, reboot them, resize
them, reinstall them, and so
on, you can do this via the
HTTP-based API from whatever
language you want.
We also offer a higher-level
client in Python.
But if you need to do cluster
management operations, like
initializing the cluster in the
first place, adding more
physical machines to the
cluster, doing some other
not-so-usual cluster operations,
then you need to
revert to the command
line API, the
command line interface.
So internally, we have tools
that use both of them.
And this is not an ideal
situation, and we are trying,
long-term , to move to offer
full parity between the two
interfaces.
But so far we have
this disconnect.
Now, something slightly
more technical.
Once we have dealt with the
processes and how we think
about Ganeti, how do we
actually deploy Ganeti
internally?
We have two main release modes
that we do in Ganeti.
One is what you call
a major release.
Here we have release
cycle that is a bit
longer than we like.
We do usually seek around
six months.
And in the major release cycles
is where we add major
and backwards-incompatible
features.
And because of this,
we do a very slow
rollout of the new Ganeti.
We start with a beta release.
This is the point that we first
announce both internal
things and external on the
external developer mailing
list that the features
for the new
release are kind of frozen.
At least are testing your
tools that interact with
Ganeti and so on.
And probably here we have a
couple of weeks until people
test and see what changes they
need to update in their tools.
And internally, once all the
teams have confirmed that
compatibility with the new
Ganeti API is OK, we start
[INAUDIBLE]
process.
And we usually start on one or
two Ganeti clusters, and roll
out incrementally, in a dramatic
fashion, two, four,
eight and so on clusters.
By the time we reach about 60%
of the fleet, we have quite a
large deployment internally.
We say, OK, the new version of
Ganeti looks good, and we make
the .0 release.
So whenever we publish an
external XY.0 release, then
you can know that it's been
tested on the Google fleet and
it works well.
After this, we start we stop the
incremental route and do a
full-scale roll out on
the internal fleet.
The problem that we see with
major releases is that being
incompatible, it's harder
to roll back
from a major release.
So this is why we are very
careful in making sure that we
only roll out on a wide scale
after we know that the
likeliness of to need to
roll back is very low.
On the other hand, when we have
a minor release, which
takes us, for example, from XY.0
to XY.0 plus 1, we try to
keep these releases small.
It's about a month between
them and they are fully
backwards and forwards
compatible, so you can just
install the new version of
Ganeti, something's broken for
you, you can easily revert.
Here, we don't have such
a longer [INAUDIBLE]
process.
We just do one or two weeks of
[INAUDIBLE] on a couple of
clusters, and when that is done,
we roll very quickly to
all the fleet.
From time to time, we do add
some new features in the minor
releases, but they are, again,
backwards and forwards
compatible, so it's not actually
a problem to do this.
After discussing the deployment
model, I would like
to discuss a bit about the
development model.
We run not a very complex
It's the usual write code,
test, and so on.
The difficulty or the challenge
here is how do we
integrate actually requests.
Being an open source project, it
is used both externally and
internally an extensive way.
The problem is how to prioritize
requests both from
the internal things.
For example, we have requests
from customers.
They want their VMs to behave
slightly differently.
For example, we have a group
internally that runs software
load balancers on top of Ganeti,
and they've seen that,
when live-migrating VMs, it can
be that the delay during
live-migration is high enough
that it disrupts the software
load balancer operation.
So they want features like
being able to mark VMs as
never live-migrate.
It's better to do the HA at
the application level, and
it's fine to shut down the VM.
We also have internal requests
from the operations team.
How, for example, to make sure
that Ganeti behaves better
when you need to emergency shut
down a big cluster of
Ganeti and you don't care so
much about the clean shut down
all the VMs, but instead making
sure that you get the
storage consistent in the
shortest amount of time
possible, and so on.
And the same when you bring
it back up, and so on.
Besides this, we also
have requests
from external customers.
And the interesting part about
external people is that, even
though they might deploy Ganeti
on the same scale as
you do both in small clusters
and both in large clusters,
they run it in different
modes.
So, for example, when you
initially develop Ganeti, as
Google does in your shared
storage, we simply offer
support for local attached
storage.
So people started asking,
can you support
at all shared storage?
Yes, but it's not a priority for
us, please send patches.
And indeed we had some
significant contributions, for
example, from the
Greek Research
and Education Network.
They are our biggest external
contributors.
And they added shared storage
support, and you have a
different number of
options there.
And they also added
something that--
as I mentioned, inside Google,
we have machine
databases and so on.
And the machine database
contains things such as host
names, MAC addresses,
IP addresses.
So when we developed Ganeti,
from our side, we don't need
Ganeti to handle this.
But other companies that run
Ganeti, they don't have this
level of integration, so people
said, maybe we should
add things like network
management in Ganeti so you
can have single-place solutions
for all the
management of also networking,
not only storage and
virtualization.
So it's good when external
requests come with patches.
This is very good.
Sometimes they don't
come with patches.
So it's always a question of how
do you prioritize internal
bugs, which are in the internal
backtracker, versus
external bugs, and so on.
And it's not always easy to
manage their release cycle to
satisfy both internal and
external customers.
And lastly, we have features
that we, as the development
team, want to add to Ganeti.
These are not short-term
features.
Usually we know that, by this
time next year, we would like
Ganeti to have this and this
feature added, or evolve in
this direction, based on where
we see the use inside of
Google going, or the industry
trends, and so on.
So it's always a balance.
After selecting the feature,
usual write code part starts.
We use Git for version
control.
So this allows us to work,
both when working in the
Google office or when
traveling or on a
plane, which is good.
We use Python and Haskell for
Ganeti, due to a historical
accident, or so to say.
Most of the interaction with the
machine is done in Python,
but there are some parts
in Ganeti like capacity
calculation, cluster balancing,
and so on, which is
more of mathematical model and
maps better to Haskell.
On top of that, we use a
standard, [? no-based ?]
build system, [? autoconf ?],
[? automake ?]
and so on.
And we use RSD and restructure
texts for documentation.
So these are all very
standard tools.
And in general, all our build
system and developer system is
based on open-source software,
so external people can
replicate our entire
setup if they want.
Once this is done, we run tests
locally, of course.
The test system is again,
very standard.
In Python, it's based on the
standard unit test library.
In Haskell, it's based
on QuickCheck.
We also use Shell test, which
is an open-source tool for
testing command line tools.
And after developers run
tests locally, we
move to buildbot try.
Buildbot, you might
be aware of.
It is an open-source continuous
test environment.
We use it very successfully
internally.
And they use Buildbot to make
sure that any tests that
developers run locally also
run in a certain pristine
environment so that we don't
have variations due to laptops
or desktops with various Python
libraries and so on.
And unit test only solves
part of the problem.
For the other part of the
problem, which is testing how
actually Ganeti works on the
real machines, we have a QA
environment.
But because of the QA
environment, a whole QA run
takes a lot.
We usually do this in parallel
with the review process.
So what does the QA environment
do is go upload
that version of Ganeti that we
wa want to test on actual
physical machines, initialize
a cluster, add all the
physical machines to the
cluster, and run through
almost all the operations of the
cluster that you can do.
However, the downside of the QA
environment is that Ganeti
is quite complex.
It supports seek storage
backends, [INAUDIBLE]
free network backends,
it supports free
virtualization solutions.
So it's not feasible to test
all of these combinations.
On top of that, KVM which is the
most complex backend, for
example, has over forty
parameters.
And there are some bugs which
manifest only in certain
corner cases.
A recent example is, for
example, that if you take KVM
instance, and you run it with
VMC frontend, and with the
custom key map, and you
live-migrated, this triggered
bugging Ganeti.
But only in this
configuration.
So while we do a test the
actual configurations we
deploy Ganeti internally, we
cannot test all the possible
configurations of Ganeti.
And here we rely on external
people to actually test setups
that we don't run and maybe
don't think necessarily of,
and see how it works for them.
So while the QA runs, which
takes usually between one and
three hours, depending on the
configuration, we do the code
review process, as you might
know, inside of Google.
Or code goes through a review
process and we keep the same
model for Ganeti even though
it's an open-source model.
And here again we use the
standard open-source tools.
It's git format-patch, git
send-email , and a mailing
list-based review process.
In the review process, we care
about things like, of course,
code quality and so on.
But also style compliance.
We try to have a consistent
style across all of Ganeti
code base so that new developers
can easily come and
touch all parts of the
code base and so on.
And once the review process is
done, and, actually, hopefully
the QA process has passed
successfully, we commit the
code and then we push it to the
[? option ?] repository.
And again, the repository
is fully visible.
We don't have an internal
repository, and all the
comments go to the extent of
Git repository, and you can
follow the development there.
And also, the design process
if I mentioned also is the
design documents are also inside
the Ganeti source tree,
so you can watch the design
process going exactly through
the same thing, except no
unit test for design.
But again, review discussion on
the mailing list and so on.
Once the code is pushed to the
tree, Buildbot again will go
and rerun now the officially
committed code, unit tests a
longer QA this time.
And once that's done and all the
Buildbot tests are green,
then basically we are done with
the feature and people
go, look at the [INAUDIBLE]
again, internal, external,
and start
working on a new feature.
And with that, thank you.
I pass it back to Jeff.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF BATES: So I know we've got
a few minutes left here.
Hopefully this is
has been useful.
These are the lessons that we've
learned as Google has
grown, and the various tools
that we've used, and how we've
moved things forward.
Given the last few minutes we
have left, if there are any
questions I'd love
to take some.
But thank you all for coming
and I hope you've
had a great day here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you could say a few words
about how you manage developer
laptops, especially with
regards to building them
before and upgrading or
repairing after damages.
JEFF BATES: So when you're
talking about damages, are you
referring to the physical
damage of the machines?
AUDIENCE: Anything that would
require a replacement of the
hard drive in particular,
I guess.
If the developer's data
has to be migrated.
JEFF BATES: Bob, do
you want to--
since you get to deal
with that often?
ROBERT: So I'm Robert.
I did another presentation
earlier this week about how we
do internal support.
So your question was,
how do you deal
with developer laptops?
We actually have some policies
in place where you're not
actually supposed to store
code on laptops.
But typically, when you're
talking about hard drives,
they are encrypted.
So we do a data transfer to a
new hard drive, and replace it
in the laptop.
Or, if it's going to take a
long time, it'll be a new
laptop with a similar build
laptop, but a new laptop.
And essentially copy over the
critical stuff we can.
Essentially we build it
for the user and get
them on their way.
Does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: I was interested in
how you establish the base
images for what the fresh laptop
install looks like.
ROBERT: So the images we use to
give out to just anybody?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT: Yeah, we could talk
a little bit about that.
We have basically standard
images for each
model, or each OS.
So Windows, Mac, and Linux.
And then, from that standard
model, there's typically
recommended packages that you
can install for developers, or
for someone working in legal,
or for someone working in
business applications.
And that's basically a vanilla
image, and then the user
basically determines what
they need with a
recommended list, usually.
And that's usually set up within
the first day or second
day that they're working.
Does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess so.
IUSTIN POP: And if I just might
add something here.
What we try to do is make sure
that most of the developer
builds and so on are not
on the actual laptop.
So you use the laptop for a
regular machine, but, as I
said, we use extensive internal
virtual desktops.
So people get the laptop, but
the laptop is mostly used to
connect to a virtual machine,
which runs in the data center,
and there you have all your
desktop environment, built
environment, and so on.
So this mitigates, to a
certain degree, the
replacement of the
laptop and so on.
JEFF BATES: One of the other
benefits of moving--
I was talking about moving
to the cloud earlier--
we use Docs for almost
everything.
Which means that, for anything
that has been written, whether
I'm using my Chromebook, or
whether I'm using my MacBook,
or whatever else might
be, I've got it
then, there and available.
And we try to apply that as
broadly as we possibly can in
terms of all types of
information as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So I know you guys
write a lot of code.
I'm just curious how similar
or different your SDLC and
your tools or processes look
compared to the product
engineering teams.
IDs, the same practices
and standards?
JEFF BATES: As closely as we
possibly can, we try to follow
the same practices
and procedures.
There's a little bit of variance
in terms of some of
the tools the we build, for
instance, like how you have to
do compliance sometimes,
and things like that.
You have, shall we say,
non-technical external forces
which will shape how you have
to keep data, and how it has
to be made available,
and all of that.
And so in that case, we will
have to do something that is a
little bit different.
But by and large, we try to run
exactly the same way as
the prod environment does
as well and keeping
with the same practices.
So the same code reviews that
go through, making sure that
all the engineers who are
looking at it that they're
working in the right language,
and that they're following the
same policies and procedures.
And actually, in fact, there
will be people who work within
Corporate Engineering who have
come from the production
environment, and vice versa.
That's one of the things we do
a lot of within Google, is
encouraging people to work
within different areas.
And so there's this
Circle of Life.
But that would imply that people
are dying, so we try to
avoid that part.
But other than that, it is
something where we try to keep
that circle inside of there,
so that you get the
information that people have
learned from working on the
production side that they can
apply within the internal
environment, and vice
versa as well.
So barring external forces,
or another need set that's
associated with it, we
very much try to
follow this same thing.
It's a little bit different when
you start to talk about
if we are integrating something
that we bought, for
instance, because that's just
kind of a different
development model
at that point.
When you're using something that
is quote unquote "off the
shelf." But when it comes to all
the things that we build,
we try to adhere to
the same things.
But one of the things that we
really try to do that may be a
bit different is developing as
much as we can on top of the
cloud platform, because it
just makes life way, way
easier for us.
And we've got a different scale
that we're working with
at that point.
So that is the difference
as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
And as and enterprise IT guy, I
appreciate when you rub off
on the product team, as
far as compliance and
those external forces.
JEFF BATES: Yes.
The expression they get
sometimes when you have to
explain things is slightly
priceless as well.
You have to do what for what?
You don't even want
to know why.
AUDIENCE: OK.
May ask, it wasn't completely
apparent to me.
Of this infrastructure and the
tooling you mentioned, like,
for instance, Ganeti.
Is that what's bugging up
product development, or is it
also what's behind the external
products, like Gmail and--
IUSTIN POP: So as you mentioned,
this is only
Corporate IT.
So for example, Ganeti is
used for the internal
system, as I mentioned.
DNS servers, caches,
and so on.
But not for the prod network.
Those are very different
in that sense.
We use Ganeti for the non-cloud
part, and all those
are cloud product,
in that sense.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Now I would like to ask two
specific questions.
What sort of virtualization
technology Ganeti uses?
IUSTIN POP: So Ganeti supports
Xen and KVM as
production-level hypervisors.
We also have LXC as an
experimental mode.
Please try and report back.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the last one is I would
like you to add a comment
about how do you handle
diversity.
Because you obviously have a
large fleet of machines, how
do you handle diversity
on operating systems?
I mean, running different
versions or
the stuff like that.
IUSTIN POP: So the way Ganeti
itself deals with operating
system is that you simply have
to give operating system image
definition.
It's a very simple API.
You have to provide
five scripts.
One for creating the operating
systems, one for renaming
them, import, export,
and so on.
Internally, we don't run very
varied operating systems.
So we run very standard
Linux and so on.
The parts that we cannot
virtualize are the ones that
are not certified
to run on their
virtualization and sold on.
So while Ganeti supports
multiple operating systems, we
don't have a very heterogeneous
fleet.
And this is, again, a difference
from external
deployments, where usually
you have heterogeneous
environments.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you try to minimize diversity
in your fleet?
IUSTIN POP: As much
as possible, yes.
We have exceptions, of course.
And if it needs to be
an exception, of
course we allow it.
But we try to keep it
homogeneous because it's
easier to manage that.
JEFF BATES: Well thank you
all for coming out.
I think we are 30 seconds away
from the end of our time.
So have a wonderful evening,
and thank you for coming.